vibrations
hockey
dans ça tourne à temps
oui en place axa paysage ou sur les
oiseaux qui vont passer au dessus la
base tourteaux qu'on peut leur être là
c'est joli ça voilà
ne pas auprès de chant main pas
les grecs
je lui sers à rien
et que je fais un voeu dans la flotte
je vais pas fait l'aveu et 500 lâchait
détache pas en voilà c'est bien son père
ayant fait peur
et je
perds dans l'image la route aussi
faudrait boulot aussi beaux les
magistrats jean cela il faut pas que tu
es vivant n entretient pas au cube
argent le soleil ce super bowl on le
tourne mais je sais pas ce que ça va
donner un
os ya divers bertha
dessus pour voir je lui avais fait un
joli
dhd olalalala c'est pas bon en sia pense
qu'il faut se poser est déconnecté
reconnecter la boule d'accord t'as des
connecteurs ont dû lui ont dû jouer
votre manière isabelle pense pas non
pour avoir fini le studieux mais je
pense que c'est failli c'est peut être à
d'autres
penchent sur la blanche colombe arrive
dessus toi
un peu large bande
devrait le suivre vers le pays très joli
c'est prendre par derrière dois-je et
pas juste pas tant que ministre elle
n'arrive en arrive sur le
bozar
kelkoo
n'était pas si tu te fais pas ça elle
arrive en face à toi ou tous les autres
et en face à el paso ça donne ok attends
je vais je suis là un peu plus tard et
avec la brillante la
weed beaumont à 10 face à leur arrivée
face à toi elle censure h par la ville
vont continuer
enfin bon coup de pied au c pour ça
bruno bravo franck
les coupes
tours
ah c'est beau ça regarde regarde
palabres à la doxa
repêchage carrière je sais pas
et bon
attention était pas mal ça
tout en bas là non oui
bah non seulement des détails à port ste
perroquet marcelo cook est à ça marche